it's a wednesday edition
of the hiatus version of the pft live
pft pm
podcast one day away from a removal of
my
vampire rogue wisdom tooth it'll
probably be a while until you see me
again
assuming that all goes well even
if all goes well i'll be swollen
tomorrow and i probably won't do it also
i'll be still under the influence of
some sort of medication
although again won't be much less of a
quality of product than you're
accustomed to either way
i'll probably be back by monday and
we'll we'll do it then but we've got
plenty to do now before we get to the
point where i have my
jaw cut open and an impacted tooth
forcibly
removed with power souls let's get to
you can tell i'm really looking forward
to this the saints have
signed tackle ryan ramczyk to a
long-term deal and we know the drill by
now
and first of all this is the prime time
to work out
extensions everything has slowed down
everyone is removed from the fray
people really aren't taking full-blown
vacations yet
take care of some business get some
contracts negotiated make sure the guy
has full security
before he shows up for training camp
when he puts himself at risk again
so ram chick's deal highest paid right
tackle in league
history of course that's what the agent
told the people that broke the story and
it very well may be true
but i like to wait for the numbers to to
really get a feel for
how good or not a deal may be i remember
two years ago xavier howard's contract
highest paid corner in league history
well when you broke it down it really
wasn't that great of a deal and
in the two years since then xavier
howard has come to that conclusion
himself so
we'll see what the real numbers are on
ryan ramczyk but bottom line is whatever
the saints offered
he accepted certainty security
and the saints have one of the best
players under contract for years to come
as they transition
to life after drew brees and the
all-important question of who will be
the starting quarterback week one and
beyond will it be james winston will be
taysom hill one of the things to be
figured out during camp
one of the things to not be figured out
during camp will there be an extension
with ryan ramczyk one of the big
questions early in the offseason was the
dak prescott
contract obviously he got it done and he
got
a massive deal a better deal frankly
than patrick mahomes although
patrick holmes deal is worth a half
billion it's a deal that lasts
11 or 12 total years from when it was
signed dak prescott got an excellent
contract
a four-year deal that as a practical
matter will be renegotiated after three
or he could walk away as a free agent he
walked away
from the question of whether or not he's
been vaccinated and i understand
this is a very political issue i
understand that
somehow this has become the latest thing
on which we are divided on as a people
but i need to say this again as it
relates to the question of whether or
not it's anyone's
business whether or not an nfl player
has or hasn't been vaccinated
this is a different job than
pretty much any other job in the country
because
already when you sign up to play in the
nfl
your health is an open book every week
if you're injured in any way it gets
disclosed
if you have an illness it gets disclosed
if you've got tonsillitis it gets
disclosed if you've got
appendicitis it gets disclosed there are
no health secrets because
your availability as a football player
is a critical piece of information
especially as legalized gambling
continues to spread throughout the
country
so if a player isn't vaccinated and
therefore susceptible
to the possibility of a sudden finding
on any given day and he will be tested
every given day for covet 19 any one
test
sunday morning game day you're positive
you're not playing
whereas for the players who are
vaccinated as we reported at pft a week
or two ago
you only get tested once every two weeks
that's it
so which guys are gonna be the ones who
are at risk
of finding out on the day before a game
or the day
of a game that they can't play it's the
players who aren't vaccinated
it's fair game to have that information
available it's another factor
to be considered now look how much
risk do you assign to the possibility
that dak prescott all of a sudden won't
be able to play
on a given sunday i don't know but it's
just another factor that goes into the
analysis
it's another thing about which players
and teams in the league
need to be transparent so
look i i get it and i've made this point
before and of course it gets
a lot of people triggered folks who
otherwise could give two craps about the
rights of players
all of a sudden are supporting the right
of a player to not say whether or not
he's been vaccinated
this is different this is unique
this is the nfl where your health
is an open book and it's fair to ask
and it should be expected that the
player will answer
whether or not he has been vaccinated
frankly take it out of the player's
hands
it's information that the team should
make available it's the information the
league
should insist on teams making available
so that people who are wagering their
hard-earned money on a given football
game will know
whether or not there's a chance the
morning of the game
the starting quarterback isn't going to
be able to play directly because he
chose
not to be vaccinated get a phone call
and now i'm not getting a phone call i
have to call that person back sorry
about that all right let's move on to
the next topic
tom brady speaking of vaccination i this
is something sims has said i haven't
written this yet at pft
because it's one thing to talk about
it's another thing to reduce it to a
written story and then let the trolls
have at it
but sims and i discussed it within the
past couple of weeks maybe once or twice
i think on the air there's a chance we
talked about it during the break but
what the hell
sims is convinced there's no way tom
brady is vaccinated
because sims says brady won't even use
sunscreen
he doesn't want any chemicals touching
his body
directly or indirectly inside her
outside so he's not going to want the
vaccine
and he's going to think he's impervious
to covet remember last year the only
thing we have to fear is fear itself
i'll be interested to see if anyone
doesn't fear asking tom brady the
question there's a lot of there's a lot
of questions out there
that we have for tom brady it starts
with are you vaccinated well someone
asking that at training camp it
continues to
who is the mother bleeper to whom you
were referring
when you appeared on hbo's the shop
uninterrupted
and third why are you endorsing subway
that's been the big story over the
course of the last day and it's amazing
to me and i try not to
i i try not to give credence to the
reactions that people have on social
media
i pay attention just out of curiosity
and sometimes it's entertaining and it's
fun for me to
engage in the banter but
it it really is strange that people get
angry when you point out hypocrisy like
tom brady would never go to a subway tom
brady would never
eat subway food and i understand when he
was in college he did but this isn't tom
brady in 1999 this is tom brady now
tom brady now will not eat subway tom
brady now will not feed subway to his
family
tom brady to coin or to borrow from
randy moss's freight
phrase would not feed that bleepety
bleep to his dog
but tom brady's collecting a check from
subway
is it not hypocritical it's fascinating
to me
and i think it's possible to believe as
i do
that tom brady is the greatest
quarterback of all time
arguably the greatest player of all time
at any position when you consider the
tangibles and intangibles
in the history of the league but he's
also a hypocrite
clearly a hypocrite read the tb12 method
got a copy of it got a signed copy of it
personalized
signed copy of it and i flipped through
it yesterday
chapter eight nutrition i quoted some of
it at pft
clearly subway products frito-lay
another company for which brady appeared
in a tv commercial
we need potato chips not on a regular
basis sparingly
hardly at all not food is how he would
describe
chips and subway and we know not that
long ago he
applauded ronaldo for dissing coke
products
at whatever tournament was going on and
uh yeah they sell coke at subway as well
so
i hey i'm not going to begrudge anyone
the ability to go make a living
that's fine go make as much money as you
can he's already got more money than
he's ever going to need if you got a way
to make more just by lending your name
to a product so be it but
it's fair for us in the media or anyone
else to say wait a minute wait a minute
wait
wait wait a minute tom
the last guy if you were making a list
of the guys least likely in the
world of sports to have a deal with
frito-lay
and subway it would be tom brady
least likely and there he is i got no
problem with it go get paid tom
but man a sucker really is born every
minute
and there are going to be people out
there who who maybe don't follow the
sport as closely as the rest of us do
and if you're watching this that means
you follow the sport closely
we know tom brady ain't eating no subway
we know tom brady ain't no doritos we
know
but he's also getting paid to directly
or indirectly create the impression
that he does devante adams continues to
be
in the news there were some comments
recently from raiders quarterback derek
carr
who was a teammate of adams at fresno
state
carr would very much like to reunite
with devonta adams it's okay for a
player to say it's not tampering now
if raiders management went to derek carr
and said go say this
then it's tampering but players can say
whatever they want directly indirectly
publicly privately however they want to
do it
i think i've now said directly and
directly three times make it four
during this special haters edition of
pft live slash pftpn but nevertheless
carr would like to play with adams adams
has said he'd like to play with carr the
question is what happens with the
packers contract and more importantly
what happens with the
quarterback situation in green bay it's
going to be a strange year for davonte
adams if aaron rodgers isn't there
because if jordan love just doesn't
click if it doesn't work
it's going to hurt devante adams numbers
may make it harder for him to get the
kind of contract he's looking for next
year in free agency
if rogers is there could be a big year
for adams
again adams could walk away next year
and you know
if we talk about the possibility of
adams playing for the raiders
it may not be a reunion with derek carr
in las vegas maybe a reunion
with aaron rodgers in las vegas
because
if rogers doesn't play next year and i
think he will be
i don't think he's getting traded this
year i think he's going to show up and
play
i think he's going to get traded next
year if the broncos
are at the table to try to get aaron
rodgers
the raiders have to be there too because
you'd rather
much rather have rogers on your team
than have rogers on
the broncos so maybe it will be adams as
a raider and maybe it'll be adams
catching passes
from aaron rodgers other news from the
afc
west the surprising revelation from
tuesday night
a lawsuit filed by a couple of pat
boland's children
challenging the authority of the
trustees that have been running the
franchise for nearly a decade now
that trial was due to begin in that
lawsuit on july 12.
all of a sudden stayed and vacated is
the trial
doesn't mean the case is over just means
the parties
jointly decided to ask the judge to
press pause on the case now that only
happens when
unless both sides just
realized holy crap how are we going to
get ready for this trial there aren't
enough time for us to get ready we need
a continuance but that's what it would
be
a joint motion for a continuance when
you vacate the trial date and stay the
proceedings
that means that there's a resolution
that's being discussed
now no one connected to the broncos is
saying anything
publicly or privately on the record off
the record about anything that's
happening but
i think there's two explanations one
maybe they're just going to throw their
hands in the air and realize there's no
way that this
ultimate goal of pat bolan is ever going
to be fulfilled
whereby one member of his
family one of his seven children
appointed by the trustee to take over
the team because
as joe ellis one of the trustees and a
long time broncos executive has said
they all have to be on board with it and
if you've got a couple of them and this
is one of those issues
where you've got some kids from a first
marriage and
some kids from a second marriage and
they don't always see eye to eye
so the two children from the first
marriage are opposed to the idea of
brittany bolan one of the five children
of the second marriage running the team
if those two are never going to agree
then at some point you just got to throw
your hands up in the air and say we just
got to sell the thing
and that may be what they're deciding to
do let's just sell it to the highest
bidder
let's get as much as we can let's max
out
whatever revenue we can generate in this
new world of
legalized gambling where some in
ownership believe that teams
soon will be worth eight to eight to ten
billion
just the average random team eight to
ten billion not the great teams
not the cowboys not the raiders who are
smack dab in the middle of las vegas but
the average random team
eight to 10 billion so maybe that's what
they'll do the other possibility
and this is what happened with the
titans very quietly no one really paid
much attention to this
but when bud adams died his estate
split the team up into three parts to go
with the three branches of his
of his family tree his three children's
families
but he never put anyone in charge and
that was an issue that lingered for
years
what was going to happen the league
wasn't happy with it the titans weren't
happy with the pressure that the league
was putting on the titans but eventually
roger goodell got involved and brokered
a deal
where one of the three children said
i'll cash out you buy me out and i'm out
so now
it's two of the remaining families that
are running the team
that may be what happens here you could
have the five
children of the second pat bowling
marriage buying out
the two that brought the lawsuit against
the trustees and the
and and those two just move on and the
five
take over the team and britney bowlin
ultimately runs the team that could be
the possible resolution as well but
something's going on
with the denver broncos and
they need an owner every team needs an
owner the packers are the only team that
will never have an
owner because it will never be anything
but a corporation but the teams that
aren't incorporated needs
someone one person who can make
decisions who has the power
to swoop in and do what needs to be done
the league requires that
they want one person who has the
authority to make big decisions and yes
the packers have that one person but
that person doesn't act
with the same confidence or lack of
accountability
that an owner does and and there are
good things and bad things about it but
every team that isn't the packers needs
someone
like that all right i need to answer
some of your questions
and uh let's see what we got here our
good friend tom marshall otherwise known
as at a red zone elk
is deshawn watson under any pressure to
settle his case and force the nfl to
declare any punishment before training
camp
we talked about this a little bit
yesterday and let me just summarize very
briefly because i wanted to answer tom's
question because
i i in my mind it's very basic
there's value in settling the case k
says
22 of them there's value in getting them
settled before the start of training
camp because then
desean watson would not be put on paid
leave presuming that along the way the
criminal investigation is closed and if
those
22 cases are settled they would be
because part of the process i think will
be
now you can't you can't get the 22
individuals
to agree to refuse to cooperate if
they're subpoenaed by a grand jury or
subpoena to testify in a criminal action
but if the 22 individuals
believe they've gotten justice through
the civil justice system
it's a lot harder to prove anything
beyond a reasonable doubt in criminal
court so if that happens
then no paid leave desean watson
goes back to the texans or gets traded i
think that would be the more likely
outcome
and the only question then is when and
if
and how many games he would be suspended
for as his substantive punishment
for this incident under the ben
roethlisberger precedent from
11 years ago when he had two allegations
two
one was a civil lawsuit one
was potentially a criminal case that
didn't result in a prosecution that i
still believe resulted in some sort of a
settlement and even then
roethlisberger was suspended six games
reduced to four so
i thought this was going to be a short
answer sorry it's not
yes there's a good reason to settle the
case before training camp because then i
believe
desean watson would be traded to another
team broncos
dolphins eagles the three leading
possibilities in my mind
but if he doesn't settle that's when
it's incumbent on the league
to let everyone know not publicly just
privately
the texans the teams that may want to
trade for him watson's camp
whether or not he's going to be put on
paid lease so he can make a decision and
the teams involved can make their
decisions about what they're going to do
because
i still think it's hard to justify
putting him on paid leave now the
league's got the discretion to do it
and i think they have the obligation to
make a decision about it before
camp opens and to make sure that
everyone involved knows so
uh long story bearable that's
my answer so it isn't critical that
there be
a settlement but uh either way there
needs to be some clarity
about whether or not desean watson is
going to be available when camp rolls
around
pftp on policy what major nfl news is
most likely to break during the slow
time contracts trades quarterback power
plays well the contracts we already saw
ryan ram check today
we're waiting for and i think the order
is going to be
lamar jackson then baker mayfield then
josh allen
i really do think that's the way that
it'll unfold and i think the
two quarterbacks from the 2018 first
round draft class who have agents are
waiting for lamar jackson to go first
because if either of them go first then
lamar jackson who doesn't have an
agent uses the mayfield or the allen
contract
as the starting point for his own and if
jackson ends up getting a better deal
than one of the quarterbacks who have
traditional agents that's not a good
look
for the traditional agents so i think
other contracts potentially will be done
the goal is to get players financial
security protection against injury
before they show up for training camp
and look the power plays i think
are over but for aaron rodgers and we
don't know what power play he's going to
make i still think he's going to
ultimately show up
pftp and policy what are your thoughts
on the great a e documentary on kiss did
you watch it while wearing
the jersey the jersey is framed that was
a couple of years ago that the pft pm
posse sent me for christmas i believe it
was
a signed by paul stanley and gene
simmons jersey of the defunct
la kiss from the defunct arena football
league
i i never know what is going to be
available to stream
on the a e website i've tried to watch
some of the
wwe biographies some i was able to watch
some i wasn't i've got youtube tv a
e is not on there it's not one of my
providers and i just
i checked earlier today to see if i
could watch the kiss documentary
and it's there and i've watched most of
the first episode
it's stuff i've already known it's
repackaged
there's some footage that maybe i hadn't
seen before
there's maybe a way that gene simmons or
paul stanley tells the story that i
haven't heard
but but i i've known it all it's a
refresher course because it's something
i've been aware of i've read the
autobiographies of paul stanley of gene
simmons of peter chris
i don't know if ace really wrote one i'm
not even sure he can write
but uh i i know the whole story of kiss
i could probably recite it
if someone asked me uh to do it and
especially now after i've had my memory
refreshed by watching
a lot of the first part of the
documentary but yeah it's good and
if you don't know anything about kiss i
i think you learn a hell of a lot and
it's all in one place and it's
entertaining it's well done
uh but but it really isn't anything new
to me
all right to leap rao if the broncos
cannot land aaron rodgers is their off
season a colossal bust their roster
leads one to believe with adequate to
good quarterback play they'd contend but
they cannot muster such with the room
that they have i still believe in teddy
bridgewater and
teddy bridgewater is reunited with pat
shurmur who was the offensive
coordinator in minnesota
bridgewater didn't play much quarterback
if any i think he had
some cameo duty during the 2017 season
when schermer was the
offensive coordinator but i i i think
that
uh bridgewater may be the best option
the most consistent option
and their defense is still pretty good
they've got some weapons offensively
i don't know if the off-season is a
colossal bust if they don't get aaron
rodgers
and if they get aaron rodgers next year
people will forget about this year
but look it's been a drought for denver
they won a super bowl
now six years ago haven't been back to
the playoffs since then
and and that that's not a usual
occurrence for the broncos they've been
one of the
consistent contenders for years they've
they're in the middle of and from their
perspective i
i'm sure they would say they hope
they're at the end of a dry spell that
they hadn't had really since the merger
in 1970 so they need to find a way past
this and quarterback has been the issue
but the packers don't want to trade
aaron rodgers and unless rogers can work
some magic and get the packers to change
their mind
then rogers won't be a bronco until 2022
at the earliest let's see what else we
have here i was interested
in this question from delete brow he
asked several today and i appreciate his
input what is the single greatest talent
a quarterback
should have coming from college monster
arm
accuracy a fast visually processing mind
a work ethic i i think that
and and this comes from spending the
last four years working with sims
i think the monster arm and the accuracy
would kind of be hand in hand i'd say a
monster arm is 1a
and accuracy is 1b and everything else
can be worked with
but if you have a big arm and if you've
got that quick release and if you've got
the ability
to to get the ball delivered with
velocity
and force from multiple body positions
and multiple arm angles that's
the most powerful trait you can have
that's the mahomes skill that's the
aaron rodgers
skill flick of the wrist and the ball is
50 yards down the field so
a monster arm that doesn't need to be
cranked up like a catapult that can be
unleashed with a flick of the wrist i'd
say that's the most
the most desirable trait but you also
have to be accurate what's the point in
having a big arm
if it's only coincidental if the
football lands
at its intended target all right let's
see what else we have here
trying to answer a couple more been
going here for about a half hour so
let's try to wrap this up
question from burn unit can nfl owners
transfer the team or sell to their
children for one dollar before they pass
away to avoid the death tax it's not
that simple there
are legitimate ways to
move around equity to avoid a situation
where
an owner dies the family can't afford to
pay the estate tax without selling
part or all of the team and and i think
that as i mentioned yesterday is one of
the reasons why
we saw what we we saw in washington with
tonya snyder now being a co-ceo and
co-owner that's potentially one of the
reasons
other teams are going to have that
problem as the value of teams go up and
up and
up when the owner dies the person
holding the bulk of the equity
somebody's gonna have to pay that estate
tax and i i
it's it's not nearly as simple as
transferring all of your holdings
to a child for a dollar you know a
minute before
your life ends preston woods if the
seahawks have a disappointing season
more likely that russell wilson is
traded or pete carroll is forced to
retire due to pressure from wilson on
the organization him or me type of a
deal
i've been fascinated by that possibility
and
i don't know that wilson would ever say
him or me
but if wilson bangs the drum
like he did earlier this offseason if
things don't work this year with shane
waldron if pete carroll won't let them
work the way that waldron wants them to
work offensively
and wilson still insists on getting out
could that prompt the seahawks to
make a change and hey i say all the time
when you're hiring a coach you probably
should hire an offensive guy instead of
a defensive guy because if you hire a
defensive guy
and he hires a great offensive
coordinator and that
coordinator does a great job he's
getting hired somewhere else as a head
coach and then what do you do
so it could be a win lose for the
seahawks this year
if that offense is great with russell
wilson
and they get to where they want to be
and wilson's happy
and then shane waldron becomes a head
coach somewhere else you're right back
in the same spot you're in this year
so and carol got the job
before that concern really crystallized
that
you know the defensive coach with the
great offensive coordinator much more
likely to lose his top lieutenant
than the great offensive coordinator
who's got a good defensive coordinator
and it feels easier
to replace that guy because the offense
is the thing that drives the bus but
it's something to keep an eye on
i doubt that russell wilson would ever
make it him or me
but if he keeps making it known
privately if they keep agitating for
a potential trade it could be that
ownership eventually decides
we got to choose one of these two guys
and maybe we'll choose the guy that's
going to be around into his 40s playing
quarterback
than the guy who's on the brink of 70 as
a head coach
all right let's see what else we got
john ramos which head coach do you think
is going to be the first to be fired
this season or
any currently on the hot seat yeah look
i
i think that that uh
the hot seat this year consists of cliff
kingsbury
the cardinals coach and you know what
i hate to put this flag on him but we
got to put it on somebody
you know if they come out of the gates
one in five two and six
if they fall out of contention quickly i
wouldn't be surprised the cardinals
run through coaches pretty regularly no
one has coached that team for more than
six seasons and that team has been
around more than 100 years
i think if they don't make it to the
playoffs this year kingsbury is going to
be out
it isn't a prevailing thought but i
think by the time we get to the start of
the season it will be
and and what have we heard recently from
the cardinals steve keim the gm we got
to make the most of
kyler murray while he's on his rookie
contract christian kirk it's now or
never
kyler murray i don't want to get used to
this feeling of not going to the
playoffs
i think it's the next logical step in
kylie murray's career if kingsbury can't
get to the team
to the playoffs this year i think there
will be a new coach someone hand-picked
to come in
get the most out of kyler murray and get
the cardinals to the playoffs in a very
difficult
division i don't think matt and aggie's
on the hot seat i think that was part of
the decision that was made
the broad overall multi-year decision
made when they traded up
to get justin fields some would say mike
mccarthy's on the
hot seat i don't see that especially not
a guy that would be fired during the
season
um at this stage of the year
look we know we know there are going to
be coaches whose teams come out of the
gates
struggling maybe someone would be on
four oh and five
oh and six but
i i look i i i don't
i don't know there isn't one that's
really jumping off the page other than
kingsbury
now i think it's a big year for mike
zimmer i don't think he'd be fired
during the season but if the vikings
don't make it to the playoffs i mean i
think they'll be in the conversation
they're in the conversation every year
they're in the fringe
of the playoff talk every year on the
odd number of years they get it on the
even number years they don't
if they don't make it this year i think
zimmer could have a problem but not
during the season if one guy
in my mind is going to go during the
season i think it's going to be cliff
kingsbury and it would
it would require the cardinals
starting this year the way they finished
last year and remember after the hail
murray play when they beat
buffalo in that that great game
november-ish
two and five after that they start off
like that
they could have an interim coach at some
point during the season one more
question from maybe a couple more nfl
leads will you be doing an
audiobook version of playmakers i think
that's on the docket
i think so for those of you who
for whatever reason can manage to listen
to the sound of my voice you'll get the
chance to do it for about 300 pages if
you choose the audio book option but
remember playmakers is coming out
march 15 and we will
hopefully by the start of the season
have the
pre-order function up and running
available
and we'll be marketing and promoting the
book heavily throughout
the 2021 season culminating in the
release on march 15.
ideally with an audio book option
although
it's one thing for me to say sure there
will be one it's another thing for me
to pick up a 300 page book and read
every damn word of it
i have to renegotiate my contract uh
okay one more
hawkins what is your favorite michael
scott moment
that and i i'm taking this one because
there's a great book that i just
finished
the untold story of the office oral
history of the office can't remember the
exact title and i can tell you the title
right here because i've got it in my
little uh
my little electronic library of course
now that i say that i can't get to it
library here it is the office the untold
story of
the greatest sitcom of the 2000s i just
finished it it was great picked up so
many details that i wasn't aware of some
of them
blew me away no spoilers here go read
the book
uh i i
my favorite moment in the show comes
from creed
it's when someone had
pooped on michael scott's carpet and
creed walks up and says hey guys
somebody making soup
that to me is that sorry but that's the
best
moment in the entire series in a series
full of plenty of great moments
the best michael scott moment um
yeah i i liked his appearance in the
finale and you'll learn about how they
kept that under wraps if you read the
book i don't know why i'm promoting and
marketing that book they ain't paying me
to and i didn't get a free copy but it
is a great book if you want to read
something this summer
i think any of the moments where michael
scott went from being a jerk
into being a human being and
one one of the moments where they first
humanized him was at the end of the
office olympics episode where
they give him one of the fake medals one
of the yogurt lids and they play the
national anthem and he tears up that's
like the first moment that he pivoted
from just this kind of a butthole
to a guy who was just kind of a goofy
misguided not self-aware
ultimately and profoundly human being
who could grow
and develop and be sympathetic so plenty
of great michael scott moments but but
they started to work in more of those
moments where
you find yourself saying you know what i
really want
the best for this guy and you feel
ownership of him even though
he could be very objectionable a lot of
the time i resemble that remark let's
call it a day
at that thanks for some of your time
please wish me well
on twitter or elsewhere for tomorrow's
removal
of my vampire rogue wisdom tooth
there's an outside chance i'll be back
friday i'm pretty stubborn
i may be swollen up like a chipmunk but
i may be back on friday i can do it i
can do the profile
uh if need be to to disguise my
grotesquely deformed face
otherwise here's hoping we can do it on
monday if we don't talk before monday be
safe and smart
fourth of july weekend emerge with all
fingers and toes please don't drive
drunk don't shoot off fireworks drunk
and pay attention to the warning label
on every piece of
fireworks that you'll come across light
fuse
and get away that's it see you next time
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports